Keeping up with the Joneses in 2015 means,
an overpriced apartment with a white picket
fence, no kids, maybe a dog and a great sex
life.
But what does that last one even look like?
Hey Joneses, Julia here for DNews
You’re always looking over the fence to
check in on the neighbors, how are they doing?
How does my life compare against theirs?
Do I have the right TV, the right laptop?
But what about what goes on behind closed
doors?
How will you ever know if you’re having
enough sex?
But like, what is the “normal” amount
of sex to have?
It’s really hard to know.
Studies about sex are mostly about heterosexual
couples and some are even sponsored by some
company.
And sex surveys probably aren’t super accurate,
because well, people lie.
People in relationships might beef up their
bedroom habitats.
Men might add a few trysts to their list,
while women might underreport.
So take these results with a grain of salt.
One survey from the Durex Condom Company found
that 53% of Americans claim to have sex once
a week, which is close to what other studies
have found.
According to the General Social Survey, on
average straight men over 18 have sex 63 times
a year, so that’s like a little more than
once a week.
Straight women over 18 say they have a little
less sex, 55 times a year.
But it depends on a few obvious factors, like
age and relationship status.
Data from the National Survey of Sexual Health
and Behavior from Indiana University shows
that young couples do it like they do on the
Discovery Channel, more often than single
people.
But these numbers deal with vaginal sex, it
doesn’t take into account the wide variety
of sexual behavior.
Almost 46 percent of married men ages 18 to
24 report having sex 2 to 3 times a week.
Compared to single men their own age, 57 percent
of which haven’t had sex in the past year.
While men in their late 20s, both married
and in relationships, had sex a little less
often, a few times a month to once a week.
As for women in the same age range, for both
partnered and married, pretty similar story.
32% of 18 to 24 year old women in relationships
had sex a few times a week.
But for women a little older, they have slightly
less sex, 48% of married women got it on a
few times a month or once a week.
But that’s still more than their single
friends, 50% of single women 18-24 and 43%
of single women 25 to 29 haven’t had sex
in the past year.
The same goes for queer women in relationships
too.
One survey from queer women’s site Autostraddle
found that about 35% of women in relationships
had sex a few times a week.
While their single friends had less sex.
And according to a Match.com’s Singles In
America study, that’s what most men and
women want, getting busy about 2 or 3 times
a week.
And that’s just enough, not too much.
On the other hand only 15 percent of men and
12 percent of women wanted to have sex every
day.
And that’s about how often the happiest
couples do the deed according to some sources.
But some researchers, like Acacia Parks, an
assistant professor of psychology at Hiram
College think that happiness leads to more
sex, not the other way around.
So will more sex make you more happy?
Probably not.
One study published in the Journal of Economic
Behavior & Organization, found that having
more sex doesn’t make you any happier.
In fact making the beast with two backs more
often leave you wanted it less and finding
it less enjoyable.
Not to mention that fussing about how much
sex is “right” or “healthy” or “normal”
might make things worse!
One study published in the journal Social
Indicators Research found that happiness about
the amount of “getting busy” you're doing
depends on how much sex you think OTHER PEOPLE
are having.
The large study of over 15,000 people found
that the more you believe you’re keeping
up with the Joneses boning next door, the
happier you are.
The researchers agreed that in general people
were happier the more they had sex.
Like those people who are having sex at least
two to three times a month were 33 percent
more likely to report a higher level of happiness
than those who reported having no sex during
the last year and those that have sex once
a week were 44 percent more likely.
And those who had sex frequently, two to three
times a week, were 55 percent more likely
to report a higher level of happiness.
BUT that level of satisfaction decreased if
they thought other people, like those in their
peer group were having more sex than them.
So maybe stop asking if you’re having “enough”
sex.
Stopping looking over your neighbor’s fence.
And start asking if you’re happy?
Is your partner happy?
And really it’s all about quality over quantity
people.
And just you know, you do you.